There is so much
you know, conversation
around
people being replaced with
AI, which I think we
have to be really careful
about this conversation.
I was just at the
World Economic Forum summit
and everyone was just
talking about automating
people out of the jobs
and, you know,
replacing people with AI
and I just feel
like we're actually
harming ourselves more than
helping ourselves as
leaders because people will
be much more resistant
to engaging with AI or
or building AI or you
know, any kind of
relationship with it.
They're going to actively
try to make it not
part of their lives.
They're going to actively
not innovate for it.
We need to be compassionate
about this. This is a real
threat that people feel.
It's a psychological
barrier to motivation
and engagement and
productivity.